election meddling fellas I need 11,000
votes give me a break the mishandling of
classified documents it's an
unprecedented day in American history
and the falsifying of business records
Alvin Bragg is investigating former
president Trump regarding a hush money
payment just some of the 91 criminal
charges facing Donald Trump I am a
victim of one of the great political
spear campaigns in the history of our
country but how much Jeopardy is he
really
[Music]
in across four criminal cases Trump
faces 44 Federal and 47 State charges
all of them
felonies first up Trump will face
independent special prosecutor Jack
Smith's indictment the attack on our
nation's capital on January 6th
2021 was an unprecedented assault on the
seat of American democracy courts will
consider four charges including
conspiracy to defraud the United
States the indictment alleges Trump set
out to sabotage the Constitutional
process by manipulating the election in
several
States you don't concede when there's
theft involved and exploiting violence
at the capital to delay certification of
the
vote
[Music]
that same month Manhattan's top
prosecutor Alvin brag begins a separate
trial Trump is charged with 34 counts of
falsifying business records Donald Trump
has become the first former United
States president to face criminal
charges in order to cover up an alleged
$130,000 hush money payment to porn star
stormmy
Daniels
next up Mr Smith will be back to bring a
separate case alleging Trump kept secret
documents long after he left the White
House he'll face 40 charges including 31
counts of violations of the Espionage
Act of
1917 they alleged Trump stored boxes
with classified documents all over the
place in Maro frankly including some
detailing America's nuclear
secrets
finally Trump will face prosecutor Fanny
Willis in court but his trial date
hasn't been set
yet the court case will consider 13
charges against Trump and his
co-conspirators including racketeering a
law originally designed to Target the
Mafia the statute ties 19 codefendants
together the grand jury believes they
were part of the illegal effort to
overturn the result of Georgia's 2020
presidential election and alleges Trump
was the boss of this criminal
Enterprise Central to the case would be
Trump's alleged attempt to put pressure
on Georgia's Secretary of State to find
the exact number of votes needed to
win I just want to
find uh
[Music]
11,780 votes four of Trump's
codefendants have now taken plea deals
so the evidence is mounting against him
all this before even mentioning two
ongoing civil trials in New York but
what will this Litany of allegations do
to his political
[Music]
campaign the clashes between Trump's
campaign diary and his court appearances
like the one on January 15th where Trump
is dued a republican caucus and Civil
Trial simultaneously may turn the 2024
election into a crusade to keep him out
of
prison but even if Trump is found guilty
it's unlikely he would see the inside of
a cell before the
election when you go to bed at night do
you worry about going to jail no I don't
really legal appeals are unlikely to
conclude by November and if he takes the
White House for a second term Trump
could even attempt to Pardon
himself this Tri is a total
which incredibly even if Trump is
convicted before the election there's
nothing preventing him running for
office from Behind
[Music]
Bars by posing as a victim of political
persecution Trump's made his campaign
about the cases against him exploiting
the trials to Galvanize his base which
increases pressure on his own party to
back him if former president Trump is
convicted in a court of law would you
still support him as your party's Choice
please raise your hand if you
would it's working Trump's likely to be
the next Republican nominee and his
polling only improved as the indictments
were filed Trump now has the biggest
lead over his 2024 Republican
Challengers whatever happens in Trump's
court cases it's clear he'll try to play
the outcome to his political Advantage
far from damaging his primary campaign
Trump's legal storms are only helping
it